[Música]
a gestão mata gestão mata gestão mata
gestão marketing e operações especiais
matar policiais mata pessoas civis mata
bandidos também gestão mata na todos os
hospitais mata e médios que vão perdendo
a validade nos seus estoques gestão nata
empresas que trabalham no limite do
risco ambiental mata pessoas impacta
negativamente na natureza gestão na mata
mata crianças no mundo ainda oito gestão
nada na mobilidade urbana
quando o carro de serviço de bombeiros
lances polícia ou vocês ocorrendo o seu
vizinho não consegue chegar num ponto
xisto mata na makro na microeconomia e
políticas públicas não medidas tomadas
ou mal aplicadas à gestão da mata
o que mata são maus gestores
o que mata são pessoas que pensam que
são gestores quando eu olho na catedral
são pedro em petrópolis e vejo aquela
torre linda que parece um foguete
apontando para o céu
dá uma vontade de decolar petrópolis
junto em cada um de vocês que está aqui
assistindo agentes cada um que está em
casa porque tem tanto potencial a nossa
sociedade
o compromisso de hoje é avançar a
sociedade respeitando gestão gestão nas
empresas gestão pública e gestão das
nossas vidas
antigamente era muito comum engajamento
de pessoas dizer que nós vamos ligar o
pedro porteiro ao pedro presidente que
distância que hierarquia
que peixe horrorosos o único pq me
importa é o pd pessoas
a proposta hoje é ligar 2 10 o é de
estratégia ao é de ética e bioética a
estratégia de uma forma horizontal onde
cada um de nós possa se engajado
esse é o meu convite pra vocês
passear planejando a missão e executando
a missão pelo universo de dez dimensões
da gestão banca de jornal porque o
jornal uma coisa simples deve ser fácil
fazer uma estratégia de negócio da banca
de jornal
por que então elas fashion não foi o
caso dessa banca de jornal que começou
pequenininha há três gerações atrás no
centro do rio de janeiro e hoje é o
maior marketplace de transação de livros
como dizia são em sua essência da guerra
à guerra a estratégia é a guerra que se
vence de véspera e finanças
hoje nós vamos falar de finanças aqui no
ted x petrópolis
será que financia seu fluxo de caixa
será que finanças é só tesouraria
quanto vale sua empresa enquanto que a
sua empresa agrega de valor depende de
quanto que os seus fornecedores agregam
valor para você
a dimensão finanças é muito mais ampla
eu adoro machado de assis quando ele diz
que dinheiro não traz felicidade
para quem não sabe o que fazer com ele
pessoas como nós às vezes eu fico tão
desanimada frente a uma tela tudo de bi
respondendo e mails sabe a gente está
perdendo a conexão do
olho no olho será que a gente está dando
atenção que deve as pessoas na nossa
vida o nosso trabalho na sociedade
a tecnologia é ótimo quando ela serve as
pessoas e não quando nós servimos a
tecnologia conta uma história rápida pra
vocês um dos meus co autores do livro
elite da gestão é o atual comandante do
bope e ele hoje tenente coronel nunes um
dia pois só tenente
em uma das suas primeiras missões tomou
um tiro de fuzil no braço e não morreu
por um centímetro e foi ao chão e
naquele instante ele aprendeu liderança
compartilhada
ele aprendeu o quanto que foi importante
cada um saber que papel cumprir quando o
líder falta ele aprendeu o quanto que
nós temos que trabalhar em time montado
equipes que possam garantir a nossa vida
e no caso dos negócios que possam
garantir o nosso sucesso
eu vou contar uma história velha pra
chuchu agora sandálias uma das dos
primeiros achados arqueológicos perdura
no mercado até hoje interessante
sandália da história dos dois vendedores
não chega num país distante e ele olha
foi lá pra vender sandálias ele olhe diz
assim tem que ligar para o meu chefe
ele corre pega um orelhão não tinha
celular e liga para o chefe de chefe
estou voltando aqui ninguém usa sandália
e aí chega o segundo vendedor de uma
outra corporação chega naquele mesmo
mercado que ninguém usa sandália diga
correndo pro chefe dele chefe vão
aumentar a produção aqui ninguém usa
sandália peter drucker já dizia molde
seu produto tão bem ao cliente que ele
se venda sozinho
terminamos o planejando a missão
falamos de estratégia finanças pessoas
lideranças mercado ok
e como é que a gente avança missão como
é que executa missão
vamos começar com estrutura e processos
organizacionais
eu tenho aqui hoje um palestrante
primeiro ted xp pro chama tales gomes
hoje é um grande amigo em 2016
ele tinha uma startup e ganhou prêmios
no mundo inteiro eu teremos da onu do
emitir da forbes moscou outs startup
chile uma coleção de prêmios e um dia
ele aprendeu que ele precisava
estruturar o negócio dele todos os
processos para que aquela startup para
que aquele produto mínimo viável virasse
o que é hoje sócio de que padecem que já
foi do grupo da ibm
parabéns thales produção operações
logística a indústria automotiva é um
grande exemplo disso para onde o mundo
está caminhando é quem está perguntando
por que o chevette e foi meu primeiro
carro é só a questão emocional ele o
chevette certo mas voltando à palestra
hoje não tem mais estoque
o estoque está no fornecedor no projeto
de uma empresa automotiva japonesa que
eu visitei quando estávamos implantando
ela aqui no brasil eu tive a grata
surpresa de perceber que os carros
entravam de diversos modelos tamanhos e
cores muito longe do fordismo onde você
podia ter o carro da cor que você
quisesse desde que ele fosse preto hoje
escuro só a produção no parque
production por ter pois não precisam de
luz pra cumprir só está
valdisnei dizia que unir pessoas em
torno de um grande objectivo era o seu
sonho e o seu maior desafio
e isso vale para projetos pensa no
projeto de uma plataforma de petróleo
que é um investimento de 1 bilhão de
dólares aproximadamente e que vem partes
de todos os cantos do mundo
projeto estruturas metálicas eletrônica
informática o que seja e no final isso
vai instalar leiro e tem que tudo se
encaixar e funcionar
mais do que isso precisa começar e
terminar no prazo
aliás o projeto precisa terminar dois
dentro do orçamento 3 com a qualidade e
hoje em dia superando a expectativa do
cliente então alinhamento de interesses
quando discutirmos pt
bill gates marcou a minha vida eu estava
no começo da universidade e eu li o
livro dele registrada para o futuro sé
uma foto bem antiga dessa da capa do
livro que deu origem à capa e ele dizia
naquela época ninguém sabia que quer a
celular
naquela época o telefone ou em casa e
andar a dish ele disse que naquela época
que nós vamos chegar em casa e iremos
assistir o programa de televisão
quiséssemos e dar pausa para ir à
cozinha fazer pipoca e e vamos voltar
para assistir o programa seja não tem
noção como aquilo impactou a minha vida
eu quero viver pra ver isso tá aí a
string teve inovação para não deixar o
steve jobs ciúmes
o que separa líderes de seguidores
chegamos no último é o é de ética
sustentabilidade e responsabilidade
social
a trilha de o estado da arte empresarial
estão vendo uma foto ali por acaso ela
tá
tirei a identidade da pessoa
mas aquilo peixe
eu fui conhecer se fora do brasil eu
estava passeando nos estados unidos e
resolvi entrar numa loja comprar uma
tarde caubói
então chegou perto do vendedor e
pergunto é essa bota é muito bonita e
qual é o couro dessa bota é ele com
aquele sotaque de gringo piorar o cool
eu como assim a brazilian ficha do
amazonas que hoje à alta roda da moda
mundial
nova york e milão paris e cy peixinho
entrar okur era um problema de resíduo
das populações ribeirinhas do alto do
amazonas porque usava a carne e aí o
couro ficava por apodrecendo nas margens
hoje depois de um trabalho de inovação
de muita vontade dá certa essas
populações vender o couro mais caro do
que o peixe consumido naquela região
dito isso o pessoal ia convidar cada um
de vocês a prestar atenção que qualidade
no planejamento e atenção ser opção são
fatores extremamente importantes para
que a gestão da nossa vida dê certo para
que a gestão dos nossos negócios ter
certo
a gestão de políticas públicas de certa
às vezes planejar demais e executar de
menos
são erros muito mar muito mais cometidos
do que a gente pode imaginar
muito obrigado tx petrópolis
[Aplausos]